Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 219 to David PE.
One of the things we've heard for a long time
now is that if they can arrest Trump, it could
happen to you.
Here's a version of that via voicemail that's
kind of tongue in cheek.
Speaker 6: David.
Sir, this is Caitlyn from Florida, and I am
calling you with tears in my eyes to tell
you I am fleeing Florida because Trump has
been arrested.
And if he can be arrested than any of the
rest of us can be arrested.
So I'm really concerned for my well-being
and the well-being of my machines, you know,
my car and my coffee machine.
So I'm just really trying to get out of here.
Yep.
But in all seriousness, I'm honeymooning to
Montreal in the summer, and I wanted to hear
some suggestions for where I should go to
eat.
Speaker 1: Tailgate for Montreal suggestions,
maybe call in.
I don't want to bore the audience with that
right now, but I do want to address this thing
that they've been saying.
If they can do this to Trump, they can do
this to anyone.
They do it to anyone all the time.
We know that they can do it to anyone.
It's not like up until yesterday we thought,
wow, once they crossed the Rubicon of arresting
a president, then they might arrest just random
many bodies.
Now we knew that in fact, the problem all
along was there is this belief that there
is a two tiered justice system.
And I believe that that is accurate.
It's not Republicans and Democrats, it's the
wealthy and everybody else.
And even yesterday, Donald Trump was able
to negotiate no handcuffs, no mugshot.
It's private entrance, all of these different
things.
So we already knew it could happen to anyone.
The question now, of course, is.
Can you actually hold the president accountable
or is this all going to evaporate?
And if it does, of course, the right will
say it's because the charges were bogus to
begin with, and we'll have that discussion.
But we knew it could happen to anyone.
We now know that at least theoretically, even
former presidents aren't above the law.
That's a good thing to know.
If you are an American.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Finland joins NAITO and this is a major shift.
I'll talk about my time in Finland and there
are so many interesting things to talk about.
Secondly, not only could anti-woke ism backfire
on Republicans, their obsession with transgender
issues could backfire as well.
We'll talk about new polling that suggests
why.
And yes, marianne Williamson making polling
gains against joe biden.
Many of you said, David, because you don't
support Marianne, you're not going to cover
her polling surge.
I am going to cover her polling surge on today's
bonus show.
Sign up.
Join Pacman dot com.
Get instant access and you can use the coupon
code indicted or you can use the coupon code
indicated.
It's your choice, whichever you prefer.